dunkle materie das wohl größte rätsel
der physik irgend etwas dunkles muss es
da draußen geben aber experimentell
konnte die dunkle materie bisher nicht
bewiesen werden am kernforschungszentrum
cern hofft man täglich auf eine
bahnbrechende entdeckung jetzt hat die
physik der dunklen materie einen tag
gewidmet den tag der dunkle materie am
31 oktober halloween wie dunkle materie
jeden von uns auf schritt und tritt
begleitet wie gefährlich sie wirklich
ist und vieles mehr
zudem vielleicht spannendsten rätsel der
wissenschaft jetzt den klicks um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen
lavigne wird jetzt noch unheimlicher
teilchen physiker und physikerinnen
weltweit haben sich im netzwerk
interactions dot org zusammengetan und
den tag der dunklen materie auf ende
oktober gelegt der grund in diesem
zeitraum werden in vielen ländern
gruselige unheimliche feste gefeiert bei
denen es um geister und übernatürliches
geht wie halloween wie passend jetzt
wird daran erinnert dass das universum
zum größten teil dunkel und unheimliches
dunkle materie macht etwa 85 prozent der
materie unseres ganzen universums aus
sie beeinflusst wohl die ausbreitung von
licht strahlen und auch die rotation von
galaxien teilchenphysiker und physikerin
vermuten dass dunkle materie aus
elementarteilchen besteht die bislang
noch unentdeckt sind und die suche
danach läuft auf hochtouren
wir haben hier ja schon beispielsweise
öfter über die großen experimente an
gigantischen teilchenbeschleuniger wie
dem large hadron collider am genfer cern
berichtet um die verborgenen teilchen
der dunklen materie aufzuspüren sie
endlich zu entdecken und sie
experimentell zu beweisen
das wäre wirklich eine riesige sensation
dass sie existieren muss dafür sind
physikerinnen und physiker überzeugt
denn das zeigen zum beispiel berechnung
der rotationsgeschwindigkeit von
galaxien oder gravitations effekte im
weltall ja vieles was wir im universum
beobachten lässt sich nicht mit der
bislang bekannten material
ein beispiel dazu licht wird sehr viel
stärker abgelenkt wenn es an galaxien
vorbeifliegt als man es erwarten würde
es muss also etwas geben das das licht
an die dunkle materie eben nach gängigen
erklärt modellen müssten sterne dagegen
eigentlich aus ihren galaxien
herausgeschleudert werden weil sie sich
so schnell bewegen forschungsteams
weltweit vermuten dass dunkle materie
sie quasi festhält manchmal wird sie
auch als eine art klebstoff bezeichnet
der galaxien zusammenhält
der teilchenbeschleuniger lhc am cern
abend die bedingungen kurz nach dem
urknall nach mit beinahe
lichtgeschwindigkeit werden zwei
protonenstrahlen in entgegengesetzter
richtung aufeinander gejagt wenn sie
aufeinandertreffen wird
kollisionsenergie frei ihre
energiedichte ist gigantisch die dadurch
entstandene material könnte unbekannte
teilchen enthalten so die hoffnung der
forschungsteams die idee dahinter ist
ganz einfach die energie die bei der
protonen kollisionen entsteht muss
derjenigen energie entsprechen die
anfangs rein gesteckt wurde und das ist
messbar messbar genauso wie die
bekannten teilchen heißt also im
umkehrschluss wenn alle bekannten
teilchen gemessen wurden und energie
fehlt liefe dies auf ein unsichtbares
teilchen eben der dunkle materie
schließen erst wenn wir die dunkle
materie verstehen können viele wir
vielleicht besser verstehen wie das
universum entstanden ist und sich
entwickelt hat
ihre entdeckung wäre wirklich eine
riesige sensation vergleichbar mit der
entdeckung der gravitationswellen auch
noch viel größer zudem begleitet dunkle
materie jeden von uns so vermuten
physikerinnen und physiker auch wenn man
sich merken denn sie ist quasi überall
in jedem zimmer dieser welt auch hier
wenn auch nur in einer sehr geringen
menge
es gibt schätzungen nach denen ihre
menge ungefähr der masse eines einzelnen
protons pro kubikmeter entspricht also
hier werden vielleicht nutzen aber wie
gefährlich kann als die dunkle materie
er kennt alle diese katastrophalen
szenarien in denen schwarze löcher die
erde verschlucken aber die cern
forschungsteam sind sich ganz sicher
dass das mehr als abwegig ist falls
durch teilchenbeschleuniger schwarze
löcher entstehen würden würden sie in
bruchteilen von nanosekunden zerfallen
und hätten zudem weniger anziehungskraft
als ein billionstel eines staub kurz
aber das bringt uns noch auf eine
weitere these besteht die dunkle materie
vielleicht aus schwarzen löchern
das video dazu gibt es hier und wenn ihr
kein video zum thema und auch zu allen
anderen themen verpassen wollt dann
drückt mir hier ein abo aufs auge und
vergesst nicht dem genau auf die glocke
denn nur dann verpasst sie auch kein
video und ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran